bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovissimo video sono famiglie
oggi siamo su
un'area che allora io non sapevo
dell'esistenza di questa cosa ho
guardato 20 secondi ho detto no io
faccio un video su sta roba perché è
incredibile c'è un video che si chiama
vegeta contro k ma campo e fa vice io
non ho visto il video o sono guardato un
pezzettino detto no a questa cosa va
vista e va riattata quindi reagiremo
questa cosa delle scotte madre non ho
guardato tra un pò il super g la sangio
sogno di mio avversario
ciao
bello a tutti i ragazzi benvenuti a
questo nuovo video
che si dall'asp e guarda anche io ho
messo male sei qui per combattere non
perdere tempo stiamo molto calmi e
mi fa morire perché si sta benin ci sta
troppo bene ci sta benissimo a da va beh
comunque a parte il fatto che non
sarebbero le cose che dire la
vegetazione
chiesto quello sicuro 6 insegnati senza
ombra di dubbio teoria
la tua cosa è identica alla mia davvero
a beschi
ma poi il davvero come davvero
a caso
hey man giugno della morte
beh marea sono che costo facendo bene
attenzione
no no no
ma [ __ ] come la soddisfazione
mamma mia non credi di fare aiuto ma
dove ha trovato tutte ste tutti sti
pezzi di video ci sei stato tanto lo zio
sentiamo nostro video a fare ogni sigla
madonna nucleare la cosa che mi fa più
ridere in assoluto e chemical sommato
non lo colpiscono sa cosa mi fa scattare
o no no se funziona
aiuto ecco
forse [ __ ] lo sapevo che ti avevo
madonna come mi sono salvato
[Musica]
presso il ser.t certo l energia stai
zitto per cortesia banche rimane
ragazzi da allora in poi quando il
carico lana energetica e due giorni e
poi la spari a mille bellissimo
non ci credo il nei locali gay ammazzo
ti ammazzo
eccolo questo voleva
parlarmi
è un giocatore un fenomeno
fermi
vedono morire questa valle morire troppo
scusate ma edizione che ogni caso fra n
mammamia un giocatore è un fenomeno che
va il giocatore
possiamo continuare così all'infinito
non è ammesso che fa sta roba io sto
male e basta così sto male sto dai
adesso mettiamoci a fare sul serio va
bene va bene informati super sayan piano
che le richieste qua e 50 euro e lo
faccio ecco allora
regala il geniale ma il nostro è meglio
ma dai come
non mi mette in soggezione è un super
sayan ecco così è chiaro no
accadono cose complicate travasi
si male
alla pancia e
basta no ma se veramente io giuro basta
c'è veramente nell'uscita lernia e non
solo anche gli organi madonna ti ammazzo
ti disintegro la stirpe ce ne hai capito
1 questo mi fa salire l'abominio che in
l'abominio corre presso nell'ultima
tappa dio mi sto sforzando come quando
sarà accesso qua
[Musica]
o
porca vacca assoluto rosso ma più tardi
un bastardo era il bullo perché ce l'hai
più grosso è brutto deficiente vedremo
chi ci affido lo sono
charlie grosso lui ha
come la traversa formazione il super
sayan si vabbè ma non lo so fai tutto
non so mai che palle porca vacca che
male ma quando mi faccio male io grido
che male c'e questa di sicuro non ha
senso non scorderà i questo
sicuramente mentre caso così il
[ __ ] è ben chiaro in più
anziano gesù perché il ragazzo non stai
zitto perché va fatto
va bene quanti problemi quanti
maledizione
dei ragazzi tre finisce lì vabbè io io
credo che questa sia la cosa più geniale
che abbia mai visto su di me a livello
di cui forse parte nostra siamo a
livelli stratosferici se devo essere
sincero non ho mai visto una cosa del
genere bravissimo nasci mcg non sopra
bravo dell'idea e soprattutto ci sarà
tutto ciò per me curare una puntata di
dragon ball semplicemente non ne
canonica ecco però guarda questo proprio
non sapevo neanche dell'esistenza ma ho
visto spuntare qua junior versus frost
ma frost e doppiato da famiglie e quindi
grosso junior ma non sono io che son
mano l'ho chiamato voglio una vita
perché dobbiamo fare una cosa [ __ ] ci
sei
addio 3 1 2 3 dei tempi di reazione che
fanno invidia mia nonna junior ma
vederci prova di come cazzo si combatta
ma va bene fotte segato porca [ __ ] io
non so come si combatte recava un po di
training al
cioè ha preso l'audio di un video di
dragon ball
bonito junior di merda ti ammazzo la
famiglia
cera epo grossa elettori tema e
madonna con glielo da te vai così poi
così fuori noi che ci sei è un cazzo ci
sono state anche numerose cazzo è questa
roba fantastica cambiando la veloce
dice che porta mai così la facciamo la
facciamo da junior di mel tu sei mio
perché ve battuto prima strands non ci
fosse non mi incazzo mica giuro che mi
incazzo
che sei copyright altro tema kick ass
lander ma in pratica
ragazzi siete dei geni meritati
migliorino i soldi miei dischi 64 ma
dove gli skill arci art i canali per
l'amor di dio cioè ragazzi questa cosa
geniale il nome che poi tra l'altro la
cosa mi fa ridere che mai avrei pensato
di prendere l'audio proprio da un bid
rumble quindi avrebbe senso come cosa
effettivamente pensandoci il cui 2.000
complimenti bravo zio questa era le mie
book su dragon ball e meritavano da
morire scusate mi dovevo farmi giusta
perché abbiamo visto del 9 questo merita
una chance sono come te ne avevano visto
con voi ragazzi i complimenti se state
valutando misure che avete fatte solo
fan delle coupé avesse vista che non
basta cast ma il gran potere del sasso
fiera mai dato sapere tutti
sas
[Musica]